[Musique]
nous protégeons la terre de la vermine
de l'univers parmi nos agents déployés
dans toutes les grandes villes du monde
certains se sont plus illustré que
d'autres
agent tâche vous êtes l'un des meilleurs
à avoir porté le costume
mais vous avez besoin d'un équipier
ça fait du bien et elle touche les men
in black
nous avons ré problème à londres agent m
allez on y va
le monde se sauvera pas tout seul tiers
connect a besoin de moi pour sauver le
monde bien sûr qu'on pense qu'ils ont
fait un rapport un rapport non la
paperasse c'est un vrai cauchemar
tout autre au viseur
sma
sa maman
vous pourriez regarder pas essayer ces
bons démarre
est marre on va bien se marrer
il doit y avoir un gros bouton rouge
quelque part j'ai trouvé
on dirait que la chance vient de la c2a
non là franchement tu m'impressionnes